and Joe Weisenthal co-host of would you
miss today's chart that I'm excited
about is a chart of initial jobless
claims we got the latest reading today
it was just 270 k for the last week
really low initial jobless claims not
many people are getting fired in this
economy this is the blue line here you
can see this chart goes all the way back
several decades as you can see on this
white line it hasn't been this low since
like the early 1970s but the number in a
way is even better than it appears this
yellow line here is an initial jobless
claims as a share of the population so
it basically adjusts for the fact that
the population is getting bigger by this
measure we've never seen it this good
look how low this red line is the yellow
line has never been this low so an
incredibly low number small amount of
the population is getting fired they're
obviously multiple factors here there's
the decline in labor force participation
there's the aging of the population the
number of retirees but it's just an
extraordinarily few people are getting
laid off every week you can really see
it in this gold line that's my color
chart watch what you miss at 4pm you
you
you